okay playing some other person why are
the pieces off-center
why are the pieces left center come on
not sure that's really annoying
okay I think that's better now 400 bits
thanks so much
what it tried to speak it couldn't
pronounce isn't it spelled out isn't
thanks for the bit slow Canadian
historian that's true a draw is not a
loss what to do b5 I guess okay we have
a Stafford gambit just develop maybe
I'll Castle queenside Queenie - it's
reasonable to play before oh I forgot
about a five it saw the threat it could
be a threat b5 Queen d4 okay let's put
the bishop here if I might still be
possible with Bishop takes c6 ideas but
looks risky for a white ooh
this also looks looks risky for me yeah
that looks really strong
I'm just losing a piece let's take first
oh I have uh okay so that it's not
actually threatening to take the bishop
but it might be oh this is so unpleasant
make g8 it's so ugly
undeveloped in I didn't wanna play 97
because I could take and play d5 in some
line but here at least I win the night
back so it's not so tragic all I could
have taken on d4 maybe but then Bishop
b2 ok so we have a position I'm still
down the pawn pawns are ugly but I'm not
getting needed its redevelop tonight I
could lose this pawn do I Castle or do I
play I mean what do I play here playing
knight g6 ok I'm Gavin hang upon I want
to play Brook G a night of four actually
that would win h3 by force okay
yeah now that for looming I'm expecting
whoa it's not expecting that
wait neither for just wins apiece it
takes their g v g3 okay it's gonna get
weird oh this is probably really bad for
me
g5 Bishop takes takes not sure about the
sign I'm gonna go for it and see what
happens
g3 I take on h3 and it's like a pin but
another pin there's queen g4 but then
Bishop d7 what's going on no idea what's
going on here
Jib d7 whoo oh there's almost an eye
static but not quite could take on even
this is taking on e4 work
I have to go for it
my King feels so naked but this might be
everything feels hanging nights
okay the rook is always pressured my
bishops hanging my threatening maiden
one if take stakes and I'm still
threatening made in one and the Kings
like Kings almost getting mated and some
lineman after the rook takes g3 and I
eat you check huh this is so weird
that's okay I might slow on time uh
three here so it takes takes doesn't
quite work play this move and I have
this move yeah
look at this move rook F to forest only
legal move him and I win the a one row
and I actually have force mates here
here here rook h1 King takes and then
the rest is history
BAM what a game what a finish man I felt
like I was getting crushed
until I wasn't getting crushed doesn't
ice finish okay
someone clip that we need clips for for
Twitter
hey everyone this is Eric talking from
the future or maybe the past if you're
watching this in actual future I played
this game a few days ago and now I need
your help because it did make its way to
Twitter and now I'm involved in a very
heated Twitter poll up against
Grandmaster Ben Feingold Grandmaster
Daniel narrowed its key and Grandmaster
Eric Hanson I am in a very close second
with 42% of the votes
there's been over 600 votes total with
four hours left
I plan on posting this to YouTube within
the next hour so hopefully by the time
this video is posted or else it'll be a
few hours left to votes the winner of
this poll gets ten gifted subs from
chess comm in the next arena Kings which
actually starts in four hours so if you
can vote for me I would really really
appreciate it I'll leave links in the
description and in the comments and and
I just really appreciate all the
viewership lately I do want to mention
one more thing that I am on the verge of
breaking 50,000 subscribers currently at
forty nine thousand nine hundred sixty
nine I'm sure I'll break it within the
next next few hours so thanks to
everyone for their support their
viewership and their feedback over over
the recent days and months and years and
and with that stay tuned for more videos
and I'll see you in the future